How do many kinds of cells arise from
a single cell during development?
Single cell sequencing technologies
and new computational tools are providing the most
detailed picture yet of this process.
In several types of studies, embryos of different
stages were separated into individual cells.
And the cells are sequestered away in droplets of oil.
What kind of cell am I looking at here?
To find out the researchers sequenced each cell’s
messenger RNA, which reflects active genes.
Each cell type has a profile--
a set of active genes that define its identity
as a muscle cell or a type of brain cell.
How do I track a cell through time?
In one line of experiments, researchers analyzed
some 92,000 zebrafish cells, and gathered
data from 7 different embryo stages.
To help tie the cells to a timepoint,
they added genetic barcode DNA to the cytoplasm
of some of the single-cell embryos.
These are many tiny pieces of unique DNA that
will be incorporated over time
into the genomes of daughter cells.
By the end of the experiment, the combinations
of barcodes reveal how the cells are related.
Thus, they could trace each zebrafish cell’s
fate through time to see how a single cell
gave rise to a variety of specialized cells,
such as heart, nerves, and skin.
What can this tell us?
This approach is already yielding results.
Developmental biologists have thought that once a cell
starts down a path to become, say, a muscle cell,
that it would not stray.
But researchers observed some zebrafish cells
switched to different new types – as indicated
by the change in what genes were active—after they
should have been well committed to a certain fate.
In frogs, gene activity showed that even when
an embryo looks like an undifferentiated blob--
cells are already starting down the paths
to their eventual identities.
With these tools, researchers can also see
how development differs from one animal to the next
or even learn a recipe for coaxing
different cell types from stem cells.